Well, first of all, credit where
this work belongs, fundamentally by Carlos
Pita, another colleague, this one who presented it
on the street at a conference also
on
and data science and what is that, so I
am the messenger who reduces it
a bit to the level of  humans because
people who do these things in general find
it difficult to download sometimes so let's
see how the sound comes
out the out line of the talk is fine well a little but
I'm going to set the timer so as not to
be so far from the final results
first I want to tell you a little about
what we do in jump and what are the
bing problems let's say the
auction problems that we solve then I'm going
to tell you a little it's not a
really difficult problem in general so we
're going to see different heuristics for
to relax or to simplify
the problem a bit approximate solutions found
but good the first
continuous relaxation is what we have been
using for almost two years  that solves
a particular version of the problem and
as the business has changed
this has resulted in a rather commercial cost,
it is unfeasible and we had to
think of a slightly more general boat I say
we had it in the plural as if I had
done all the work but it was thought
a slightly more general framework and that
led us to work on a convex relaxation
of the problem that we are going to see what it is
and finally I am going to say two words
because since this is pay data and this
talk does not have much country or much
data  how to press this to make
an algorithm
that computes day after day you are the
optimal auction strategy in the
markets in which we participate
so first the problems that ac
jam we are going to try to put it in two or
three words when you open
any application  which basically
finances a guitar tuner with ads
and they just want to listen to
mine and see if it's in tune and they
get an interstitial banner saying
What do they want if they don't want to buy a
new guitar? That banner basically
isn't bought in advance when they open
the application, a request is sent from
behind that says that such a phone or not,
depending on certain configurations, they
will see a banner of such a size in the
meantime  when peace and that goes to a
kind of stock market a live auction
between many platforms called
10 tracks demand side platform is like
jump others are google facebook for
example
and an auction is done in real time
basically in tenths of a second and the one
that  win direct what ad to show
then think that if one wants to
show I don't know how to make ten million
impressions
those are 10 million auctions in axis
to participate and win which
means that for her it is 10 million per
day to participate from 100 and for  choose
100 you have to have a billion
so
the quantities are huge we end up
having the order idn of the hundreds of
clients with sometimes my  them of campaigns
depending on when target and fairies are
by region participating in
auction missions and billions of ours
the 12 zeroes
basically trying to
eventually get from events rarely what
matters is showing the notice yes no
and getting some kind of a click  an
installation at an event the issue is that
these auctions are an opportunity for
more than one client and sometimes it is not
enough just to know what the
expected value of the opportunity is in each
campaign, you have to compare
shadow prices or how much we would have earned for
having shined  in another and how much we
are going overboard not of the different
restrictions that the clients are going to impose on us
so until now
we are going to put a couple of
definitions with lyricists as we
like people that there is some
mathematics to not write so much let's go
to say that we have in the field n
advertising campaigns competing for
the market of realtime building s
rtve and
the market  it basically consists of
auctions that each one has certain
characteristics they have a lot of
data it's a jason you know the whole
panoply of things that once but
basically we care about three numbers
that characterize them that are basically
the wing rate that we observe we estimate
for that auction that  having devised an
amount, see the expected cost of winning that
auction by living that amount and the number
of events of interest that we hope to
achieve in the auction here if we lived
by the campaign and showing the notice to
think that then always win reid
the cost is blind  The
only thing that matters to the campaign is the amount, how many
events are achieved. It is assumed that if the
marketing people work well, it will
depend on how well this ad is put together,
that type of thing, and
what worries us, what interests us,
good strategies.  of offer
we did not see them in strategy and we are going
to tell you that basically it is a mapping
of all the auctions to these triples  of
campaign notice and amount that we want to
show
where the good campaign was going to be the
good campaign is a notice and the bs
as it would cost me not to go there
but then put a fat cursor so
that something can be seen then basically
we are seeing this  at the auction level
but for ease and for consistency
of calculations for a certain simplification
we care about two very
important functions per campaign the
expected events and the expected costs that if
anyone is familiar with this
Polish I say with a mathematical traction you
will see that simply the costs  are
the sum over the shortlists if the
auctions where the campaign is for
agriculture,
the added costs for the campaign
were going to be the sum of the
auctions that will be assigned to the campaign and
the wing rate for the cost and quantity
of  expected events will be
simply for the campaign and the sum
over the auctions assigned to the
campaign and the wing rate given what
the video is for the amount of  events that
we hope to achieve in that campaign
with all this at hand and then this
water deaf
we can define some types of
problems and by problem we
are basically going to refer to contracts that we see
in the market that is to say how it is arranged
with each
with each client to  determine how
these campaigns are going to be paid,
then in general the most
traditional problem that this unpronounceable acronym has is
the min
maximum budget fix price, which is that we have
a maximum budget to adapt and
a fixed price is paid for each event of
interest that we achieve, and this
It will always be more or less the same
framework, our function to maximize
because basically we are a company, it is the
revenue and robinho will do for the
meeting these will be re wine and less
costs subject to and this side is in the
restrictions  that each contract imposes
in accordance with the clients in this
case we are going to have that in revenue it is the
number of events achieved by
the price  io per event - the costs this
on the strategy because depending on
what strategy we use is what events
we are going to end up assigning which auction
we are going to assign this campaign and when
we are going to spend to get them subject
to what we charge in the events
for the price is not  exceed the budget
of the campaign one thing that we are going to do
and this I am not going to stop much because it is
quite standard but instead of
writing the restrictions as what
we will charge you to undermine the same
budget we write in general what
we charge less  the budget is
less than or equal to zero for this it provides us with
certain comforts when
working expressing all the
restrictions as a function appointment
less than zero
there are mathematicians here going around that
go hand in hand well I expected there
would be none but then  I left the
raisins and take a deep breath and ignore those
details
if I eat any decorations but well but
I don't know any errors very thick
other co  ntrato and this basically what
caused the problem but we are not going to
dwell much because the treatment is
a little more dense but analogous is it
is back in this line it is the fmp of
fixed budget and maximum price instead
of giving us a price per  event they
tell us it's not right I'll give you this 10
thousand dollars as long as you get me
all the events you can
below 10 dollars per event
then the restriction of the function to
maximize is going to be the given budget
minus the costs but the restrictions
now they are going to be more on the one hand that the
budget due to the number of
events is less than the maximum price that
they gave us we are also going to wait to
operate it has not lost so our
budgets divide the cost is greater than
1 than the margin that we have left  be
positive and we add an
honesty clause if you want which is that if
we are getting events really
very cheap it is not a dollar and they said
that you can go up to 10 days  dollars do not
abuse that margin so a
maximum margin is set so the budget
divides the costs it
will have to be below 1
minus this maximum margin that is agreed upon
with
the clients
this can be extended and here we
are not going to stop much but  to another load
of problems let's say as long as
one can define this contract this
line of revenue less costs to our
profit function subject to the
conditions of the client what
we are going to ask for are basically
three things one is that the objective
be the  profit or that allows us to join
different types of contracts in a single
maximization function without making a lot of
fuss second that the restrictions
and the objectives are strictly by
auctions that is to say that we can
evaluate them in each auction it is not that
problems of another cannot be solved  style
but if this difficult problem to
compute when the restrictions
begin to be crossed will be a gift
and finally that  each constraints each
constraint is linear linear as
the English lewis costs in the
expected unit costs that is to say that
as we are working in
random environments in reality all the talks
are going to be seen that I am going to give it as if
we knew these probabilities but
in reality we only see  we only see
at the end the realization of its events,
what we are going to hope is that these
these variables with which we are
working can be expressed with a
sum of random variables that
will allow us that the lap counts
are reasonable later on, then
all said  this we are going to finish with the
first problem that is the
maximum budget and fixed price since we
have we are going to reduce the not this
always works they leak a problem they
tell you good solve it seems good what
happened with equal 1 both
small cases who I know  there is only one
campaign there is only one creative they were
under marketing and there is only one thousand
because there is only one sun  or vice participated, you don't
participate, so I'm going to think of the
campaign with a backpack in a certain way,
not where the capacity is the budget, it
is how much money we are allowed to
spend, the contract and each element that
we add is an auction that has a
weight that is basically  what
the customer is charged for participating
in that auction and a weight value that
is also the expected weight will
simply be the price per event times the
probability of winning times the amount of
sales if we win and we put the omega
which looks like a w for white and the value is
going to be the margin that we have
left, the profit, which is basically the
same as what we charge minus the
costs, that's why this formula
up to here, what some can and more from the
computing background there will be  included
is that what we are doing is
reducing the general problem to a
particular case the problem of the
packer 01 a backpack where
basically what we want is to maximize
the value  the profit for us
putting auctions in a backpack that is
the budget of the campaign some
know this problem so he raises his
hand if I hear it well it's not bad and
some of those who don't hear it
can think of if he has this has a backpack or
either they are a thief among a house they have
to start taking everything they
can to resell for the
backpack it has a fixed size that makes
them take
the TV first some better idea yet
no it is not for personal use it is to
keep one  Rolexes, grandmother's jewelry,
water pearls,
checkbooks, everything that really has a
lot of value by volume, let's say, and the small
backpack, I went with the fanny pack
and I have to stop this evil that
these terms sound like in these talks, you saw
all the apology that  correspond but
well one is going to load first the
elements of greater specific value
after the jewels this TV will come
and if they have just started wearing
the jackets then I already have  It is a truck that
height, that is, the budget is
gigantic, it agrees with taking
campaigns with very little opportunity,
composing very little value,
so what this strategy wants
basically says that what
we have to think about is the
value density of the objects  or in our
case, the value density of the
auctions, which is going to be basically the
value they have divided by their weight, and that
as the value, remember, will be profit, and
the weight was simply the cost and
density of the rum, as oral physics lagun
remembers that it is not  it is going to say that it is the
letter that is used for the density of
different liquids for us it is the
profit margin on costs it is an
expression of the margin so we make
this account we calculate the
specific value of each auction those ordered
from highest to lowest and we begin to  fill
the campaign budget up to
the knees which is an
approximation to the backpack problem
in reality when the backpack in the
ta  size of the objects compared to the
size of the backpack, that is, the
total gap compared to the cost of each
auction is they
are similar they are in order of magnitude
similar it is not so easy to
pack I can put an object this
huge with a very high value but  it does not
fit in the backpack so it is convenient for you to
put one of lesser value but if
in general for example here is a
fairly simple drawing that illustrates
a little the idea that it is if we have these little
boxes not the central rectangle in the
backpack and the values ​​that it has  writing
each box an approximate solution is to
start filling up to object 3 and there
the next one that came 2 does not fit
we stop well we put those 12 12 points together
the optimal one would actually be to put 11
points which is to put object 5 4 3 and 1
and  leave out the 2 but our
strategy that we have been saying is an
intermediate thing that is not feasible than
the relaxed solution that is meters
object of greater value and when it reaches the
last one that  The saws do not fit, which in this
case is a fabric, it begins to be
complicated. Put the backpack in. The backpack
means TV. Trying the saw and I
keep the fraction of value that if it enters
the backpack, that is a level higher than the
problem, but if the sizes do.
relative are very different
and in our case the budgets
range from tens of thousands to
hundreds of thousands of dollars and the
values ​​of each auction are in the
hundredths of a cent suppose that we
cannot cut the auctions but we can
participate or not in  some are reasonable
so until now what we are going to do
is simply order all the
opportunities when I saw a single
campaign and participate in the best ones by
value density now what happens we can add
one more campaign because perhaps we
oversimplified the problem well if
we did the assignment well imagine
that
we filled each campaign with this same rule of
assigning auctions from highest to lowest
specific value and we were seeing what happened
we fill all the budgets
and we say we did well the allocation is
optimal this someone can think of
a way to test this mean in
slide and the same so
this good the traditional way is as if
by absurd somehow if this was
the optimal allocation of  or any
change except a campaign an auction of
the campaign there and I move it the jack and I do
the math back if it turns out that I
got more value I did things wrong
because by definition I said that this is
an optimal allocation so this
gives us a way of  see if we are correct or not,
that is to say, let's take an
auction that is in the campaign and this little
box here with its own small red value
and raise it remember that now
the density will depend on each
campaign because the prices are different
think of it in a way that each
backpack assigns different values
to things in one refrigerated backpack they
're carrying meat and the other is a
backpack I don't know how a d  ura to take
your computer so if I take out the
auction there from putting it up for auction here from the
campaign there and added jack to the auction
I have to recover that peso that I
emptied in the auction there what was this w
is a jack and take it out for double  If
I go up I have to complete in
and double the weight that
campaign j adds, I have to remove from campaign
j at what price am I going to be able to get
those bits that I added in one and take away
from the other to make this transfer
that I proposed is what  it will determine if
the assignment is well done or not and if
we did if we were
loading auctions in the campaigns
following this order the next
auction if I remove any one from the
campaign there it will be outside the margin of
replacement at the worst density to the rice
star rise  that is written here
below the campaign and in the photo campaign
I am going to have to remove that same sea
that does not make sense to remove
opportunities of better margin everything
fundamentally saying a little
something  ebra what you see is that we are going to the
last rule is to assign the auction here to
the campaign and basically according to the
campaign that maximizes that account that
was at the bottom of the slide and that
now appears above, which is what
maximizes the
discounted margin  the
replacement margin is to say that the weight
of the auction maximizes the cost multiplied by
the density and this account remember that
as the ro is the value divided the weight is
basically the value that I obtain in the
campaign and minus the replacement value
of the  campaign and compared against the
value of the campaign acosta against the
value and the replacement value of the
campaign j this is quite intuitive
because think that if any auction
for example serves me in the
campaign and gives me a margin of 50% and in
jp's campaign gives a margin of 10%
one would expect that the ideal would be to assign it
to the campaign and well I know they have a
higher margin because the campaign is
performing very well and you manage to create
opportunity  margin is 45% and the
jack campaign is a disaster we are
going to a loss minus 10% 50% against 45 there
is little difference with an
opportunity of 10% when he is losing
at a loss at 10 that auction is a lot
for more than campaign  per campaign it would go in
the campaign and it is convenient for us to take out the
j campaign then instead of
swapping between the billions of
auctions having a problem what
and known np difficult it is
computationally horrible and it is horrible because it
basically takes a long time and it is not easy
to compute or  what we did is good
we are going to try to estimate what is the
worst margin that could buy day after
day in each campaign and use it as a
weight of the values ​​that I am
estimating that they are going to make
the profit with that auction in each
campaign this rule  What we say, the
row rule consists of finding that optimal frontier in some way,
and this is basically
what we have been doing for two years
with a certain process, adjusting
every day in different  directions
depending on whether we are going over
budget or falling short of that
kind of thing but it has a couple of
problems mainly that we don't know
much about the convergence of this
so when it works well it works well
but the day it comes the day it goes
wrong  you don't know why besides this
these require a lot that we are going to
express the problem in this way of
having a value that depends a lot on
the events having a price
and in general it does not allow to
easily derive some things such as what price to
pay in first auction  price and
other smaller issues
so fundamentally what we
want is a slightly more general framework
to deal with this type of problem but
let's keep in mind that this is a
reasonable alternative to work with such
fixed-price contracts
remember that in the other contract that
we  I mentioned they give us a fixed budget
and the price and the maximum price and the
margin becomes an endogenous variable
not  we don't know
sorry across the sea that they are the
indigenous area and the price is not fixed we
don't know in advance how much we can
charge for the event because that will
depend on how many of us when
we can charge for each auction because
we don't know how many events there will be  to generate
then you can adjust the price so
that the margin is within what is
convenient for the client
then the rule of that of ordering by
specific value blows up
because I don't have what to calculate it with
then the farm no longer
as we go for a long
time  fast then orange no if
some countries agree on the principle the
faculty of the secondary is a technique
that allows us to save
constrained optimization problems and
transform them into global optimization problems
basically taking the objective function
that our efe and adding
each constraint multiplied by a
little number this  star tint which is a
multiplier that is basically going to
penalize e  The value of the
objective function I continue to want to maximize
this one, the great one that did not provide citations, they will
be negative and if I go over the
restrictions, that is, if the restriction
remains positive, flavor to that whatever has
to be less than or equal to zero if it remains
positive multiplies by the artist who
has negative and we are going to try to
choose the optimal titas so that every
time the restrictions come up,
alone 60,000 h would suit you there was another
result where it did not violate the
restrictions and was within the
border that had to be remembered  with the
client and the advantage of this inheritance,
not as we said before, that we had to
express the functions of costs and
events in linear terms on the
auctions is that we can zoom in
and see what the unitary contribution
of each auction is to this equation that
I want to maximize this
france I am not fundamentally
what we are going to do what happens from up here to
the one from the crazy ele to the search that
is down there is we are going to  see what
contributions to the auction here if
we choose the campaign and the amount see and the
notice to basically avoid the end
of the events added for the campaign
there is simply the bit of the
amount of sales that the
auction achieved that the added costs that they give
the costs of the auction here and the
restriction that it also has to be
linear in the expected costs in the
expected events
remains just as linear we cannot
rewrite since you have to be
rehabilitated there and this is interesting
because the derivative of a function of
this style  where the vector is the
campaigns are an index that is the campaign
1 to 4 to 12 is not differentials I
cannot take the derivative of this count
principle see where it is maximized then I
try all the possible combinations on all the campaigns and all
the creatives
I fix which of those maximizes this
unitary contribution and this will be the
campaign to which I have to assign the
auction here, always here  so
so far so good if we know the
multipliers we have a decision rule
on how to choose live and this is
quite easy to compute because it is
the multiplications to which auction to
assign them and it also has an advantage
that can be expressed by doing a
little algebra as a  expression
that you have left that the
unitary contribution of the auction here well
it is in this campaign and it will be the
wing break of the auction to no well
for an expression minus the costs that
expression that is there in auction the
second price is what  we want to live
because it represents what
the auction is worth to us and in particular
note that basically it is a
way of weighing the raw value that is
simply because of that auction one
more thing that this is interesting we
started this crazy rhythm like this at full speed at
all rhythm is that if you take a good look at the
numbers
and this time you are going to believe this mistake
this type of star that we have here is
equivalent to m  replenishment
margin at the worst margin in which we were buying
for the campaign and in these auctions
simply with the sign changed
which is good because it means that we
did two different paths we feel
the same solution that is always good they
saw that it helps in general this to
do the  accounts of three by four and
four by three to be sure that
we have made good
improvements well in ten minutes and spend
the most hairy part we are going to see what can
be done
well we are going to say the following first
if we have certain quotes we can define
a function that  of this star that
maximizes the magnitude in the set
of strategies that basically
gives us the optimal strategy of what we
did in the previous rule is the
rule of maximizing the
unitary contribution to this function we are going to say
dual function put  a pin that
materialized to and we're going to see that that
allows us to compute the optimal strategy if
we know what these are
multiplied  res that basically weigh
how much we are going over the
constraints now it remains to be said and this
for now you will believe me that if
we find them if we find the tita sub
ops we put it as minimizing the
dual function that completes the original solution
that is the set of parameters  that we
need, which is the solution to our
original problem, then basically
we say that the current
problem of the original problem is going to be to minimize
this function q between the tt non-positive stars,
since we always not only
penalize, we do not want to praise ourselves for
having fulfilled the restrictions and that
maximizer  that min
we are going to call her star artist her voice
this because this is ok it requires
two more virtues as another title so we are going to
see how far we get but first
we are going to consider this p function of
tita to base our problem
first there is a dual that first comes  before
now you are going to see why the first one is going to
be simply this one we are going to write
a fu  ntion of minimization because it is
common in the literature but I am going to
talk about it at the end of maximization so
that it does not become confusing or for this reason it is
worse but I think it will be better understood it
is simply the PT is going to
give me the maximum of the profit function
subject to the constraints
being less than equal artists
then instead of having the original problem
which was p of zero maximize subject to
the constraints being greater than equal to
zero we have a more general problem and
what we can do is move this
tita relax or  tighten the constraints
fundamentally as long as
the constraints are more relaxed or they
for better results
then the function is going to be non-
decreasing hello the minus the function is going
to be non-increasing and in general we
can't expect this function to be convex
but
at least  least if we can expect it to be
almost continuous because if I give myself a
little more budget as the companies are so
small  auctionas is not going to go on
raids no it is not that suddenly it is going to
be crazy but it should be rather
soft so what we want to
find is p of 0 but we are going to
find an approximation that is p
star star of zero two stars
no  one on mirtha's table this is
something crazy this is where sp star comes from
is that what we are looking for
there is going to be the conjugate defenses since
it is already there we went through the branch of
mathematics but well fundamentally
the question is whether  you are any function
p and with fincher's game and
again this believe me I had to
believe carlos every day what I have
to rewrite to be sure that it
says it right is a function that basically
for each point of the function
is a  alternative representation of the
function that defines me in some
function itself tells you what the coordinate is the
origin of the tangent hyperplane the
function below
it and basically allows it to be represented
in another gr  oops of things basically
machines a parabola the parabola all
the slopes if at every point the
drift is negative it speaks derivative
even though here in this context it does not
correspond but well then for
each point you have a drift a
slope and that slope cuts the
origin in  a point for m equal to equal
to mx moves a line has an ordinate
and a slope so if the function
is convex the derivative at all
points will be different and this
transformation is with a defense game he
will not lose information and will not  only that
but it has a
basically magical property which is that if they
do it twice the conjugate and the
convex functions recover the
original function this is really magical in
black magic but they will create melo and if
the function is not convex and with a
defense game the conjugate  conjugate will
retrieve what is told the
convex hull and convex the one that is the
closest convex approximation to the
original function as completing the
holes  jeritos and the function was like this he is going to go
to eat and here he joins de castilla that
he joins he is going to fill it in so
here we go with this it can be shown that
this function that is the conjugate of
fences of the problem of the primal problem
and has another property  useful is that
first it is always convex yes
this can be minimized easier with
gradient descent techniques that
one knows and second that not at all
points but in the east at the optimal x
because remember that the function q is
maximized  goes in the optimal x at that point
the derivative with respect to you
star is equal to the restriction
evaluated in the strategy since I think
that of having lost everyone but
intuitively this is reasonable
think that the farm did not have the function
original plus a constant, that is, a
multiplier times the restriction, the
derivative of that function and remember that it
was a form on the farm in the dual function,
the derivative in those multipliers
is fundamental  mind the function that
is next to the g evaluated the strategy that
you used
so now we have a way
knowing the multipliers to calculate
the strategy and a way knowing the
optimal strategy or the one that we understand
that the optimal one to calculate the
multipliers that correspond to it this
tells us  which then we can use a
sub-gradient seat descent strategy because it's not appropriate to
talk about gradient when the functions
are not differentiable I'm going to say this one
so this should work but
there are still some qualifications left
but not much but what we want to say
is this
remember  so we start by trying to
get the maximum to the
objective function that we can explain it how to
write how to set o to evaluate
to zero and what we get is
a way to compute p star
stars from zero the double conjugate and on
this graph here imagine that  there is the
original function not the pd up here that
basically tells you  and
how much am I earning or at least because it
is negative due to this
minimization problem in half maximization
as the constraints are relaxed, that is,
as I have more space
for myself since I have that space I can
earn more money being a function it is not
convex but  the other if what's going to
matter is how far the
star star pp is from zero and if my
original function the p which was the
objective function we started with and its
constraints is pretty convex from
star is tracy p is going to be pretty
close and this solution should be
reasonably good it is not going to be the
optimal post post post but we are satisfied
and it is credible that this function is undertaken
we would say yes
fundamentally for two reasons first
because there is in return we are adding
over thousands and billions of auctions
and  second because as we relax the
function I don't know as it gives more
slack to the parameters so that we can go
beyond the budget for example the
Yields are going to be marginal if
we are optimizing well and now
that we are optimizing well it
will grab the best
opportunities first if it were to continue
getting
less interesting things from the market this is
normal and it is easier to get 100 pesos for
good events than 100 million pesos
for good  events so this gives us
certain guarantees guarantees gives us
some peace of mind that we are going in
the right direction
recapitulating why they set and paint
and data but what we do because
all this goes to an algorithm in python and
generates data that we analyze to
improve it is all the  days we have some
multipliers that we start by some
default is consistent and we are going to
treat it and we are going to use it to compute
the optimal strategy and with that with that
strategy at the end of the day we are going to use
that value to descend in the gradient
that is to say  along its gradient of the
dual function over the star and
basically this is reasonable s  If
we go to the restrictions, this
multiplier must be raised because it is convenient for us
to penalize this restriction more
to turn inwards. If we
are falling short and before we
were not passing, we reduce it and if we
are falling short of that
restriction and before it is looking short,
we leave it.  to know why he's happy we
're not screwed
there are two more things first we're
solving a problem every
day actually he's assuming that every
day is the same and this isn't
necessarily true it's quite
true because most of the
seasonality happens within the day
basically  I get hungry at
noon so I don't know if we have
any company as a client where I'm a magnet so
you can say names try
any good you'll be waiting for it doesn't
get events at certain times
there's always one that at three in the
morning  grip of the slump who knows
why because he left the after
after yesterday but in general  ral you have
these seasonality within the day
seasons day week the
monthly seasonality exists but it is less and
basically what we are going to do is
also never go towards the never
lower the learning rate to 000 to
make sure that as the market can
change there can be
structural breaks in how the
application works that had
suddenly retracted the cto does a somewhat strange thing
and the digital fabric to the whole world
things
just happen we always keep learning let's
never talk about a good post but
we make sure they continue to navigate the
market this algorithm
one last thing we talk about everything as
if we were talking about
known numbers when we are actually working
with random variables
but your
gradient descent results hold up pretty well in
the paper there are a lot of questions
to test it and there is a mr stephen
boyd who  does very well and this fact
more entertaining than me almost any  r
thing more entertaining than me at this
point but what is going to be
important is that since we ask the
restrictions to be linear in the
costs and the number of events
any reasonable estimate is added
at the campaign level it can be
extended up to  the auctions and it should
be integrated
for the variable that we are looking
for because only every day
we see the final results of how many
events we got and not what was the
true probability of getting an
event with that campaign over
millions and millions of auctions
over many days and campaigns it should be an
estimator in closed
let's try to stop for the
next output we have to first some
more empirical results with some
code basically try to assess
where is this quality cap this
difference between pp star star
how do we go about  calibrate these
parameters,
these hyperparameters of the model that
obviates the learning rate, since n  or
forget that because of how we are computing
the strategy this is the
unitary construction there in the background there are a lot
of decisions about how to estimate if
forward the expected value of things
because today we see what has just
happened but for day seven  days we have
to talk about how many events we get, we
have to be very prepared, hidden meters,
let's say in that the little formula he looks for it and
in general if this makes sense or suits us he
has a coin and see what we do that
's all
thank you very much for putting up with paying
[Applause]
[  Music]
questions
perhaps outside of what we do but you
can buy and sell the
prison space
or
take out the medical camera and I can not in
fact the fundamental structure is to have
supply side platform city man side
platforms those of mansa and those of us who are
buying traffic demanding traffic
we pay to participate in the auction and
if you win offers and if you win you
keep that space and on the other side are
the sup  ply side which are the apps that
are offering the place in their
applications in the middle is the
exchange there are several in one of the best
known are twitter maps and
google x and they are the ones that coordinate
this space there is how it is  king d
from that little boy in that world and as it
is literally live there are known
80 milliseconds to answer the
auction he may think that you are
creating and he cannot not load by the time he
arrives until the notice has to be
there it
would not be and  I find it very difficult to
imagine how it does to resell that
space, what does happen is that
instead of having an application having
its entire development team to
join this, it has a fairly large infrastructure, it
pays us to
participate in those auctions on its behalf.
so in that sense you with first
how we buy the seat in
the exchange and from there we can
offer for different clients I
answered
and some other questions  s
you said that they calculated some appointments at the beginning of the
day
[Music]
there were some weights that were pre-calculated and
once it's done you have to start with
a hospital those narrow ones are
reasonable multipliers that
basically what we do is take the ones
that would have come if we used the rule
previous
during the day you use them as they come
at the end of the day see how it went
and depending on how you moved the
modified ones a little bit you make that
descent of the tooth to see where
they go those are the ones used for the
day  next is that nothing else then
how is the loop of the strategy last
function of the multipliers and the
optimal multipliers depending on the
strategy thank you
would do more
about the topic adjusted to the
recent question they adjust per day that makes
it have the best performance when
they do on a daily basis the result of the
mathematical functions or it can be deduced
that in the long term they will have better
results for that option  continuous imization
I don't know if I explain myself well
in my opinion it's like you're going to have
better results always working
short term because you're optimizing that
way and in the long term it can become
counterproductive it's acidic or
I don't feel like a rockstar
and I got here well
the story of my life is
not the fundamental decision to make
the day work community if one
could improve certain estimates
by doing for shorter periods but
two things happen first is that the
values ​​the number of events that you
get what we call quality which
is the  cost per event is measured for
them seven days or thirty days over
long periods, with which you are
looking for two minutes and the event never arrives
in two minutes, so they will be
noisy ultras to the point of not serving
quality estimates and therefore  On
the other hand, if you take shorter units,
for example an hour, there is a basic assumption,
which is what I mentioned a bit
at the end, which is that the days are  they seem to
each other so always solving the
same problem they think that in any
gradient descent problem or the one
you assume is that nothing the distribution
of the data is the given and that does not change
and that is why it is worth going down the
gradient for the  gradient is always the
same if you take a unit that is not
the day if it is smaller the seasonality
that it has set for there are very
peak hours and others that are not and with
longer periods already for and you start to lose
certain optimal and given that  if around there I
should have updated before the
multipliers because you traveled a lot
in one direction
this is empirical the same and nothing is one of
the things we think at the moment
we are in day
there was more
ah
and the ruin the audio the recording
a question I will  talking about minimizing
the initiators of those things and a
methodology that one uses in many
areas of other sciences, which is the montecarlo method,
they have applied it at some time
as it would be, although you imagine  ginas not
applied to these goals because there you
are taking samples so you are
making the comparison of what the madman do to
get to the backpack with the
auction that they are doing so the
method of montecarlo what it does is
take all the possibilities that there are and
in a  random way because it is
Montecarlo language and to see which is the most optimal
then it is a way of not taking into
account
mathematics of each problem but
purely statistical if I know
above but it is not with a little bit of the
method above all things it would be
computationally in  feasible there
is no way with the sizes that we are
dealing with literally I don't know
number 300,000 auctions per second that
are processed on average per day
it gives you in order of several billion you
need to have many very
cheap algorithms to quickly discard some
things and basically we are the same  at the
end of the day we do not take samples but
we work with the aggregated results
but with all the  auction population
in which we participate then at least that
way a priori I can't think of how to
apply it here
when we get to a round but it's all
the theoretical paraphernalia of 9-1 we
like mathematics but above all it's not
because we like  symbols but
because
this theoretical framework allows you to save
a lot of bills as long as it
is well derived and that is key to
the times we have to handle
when answering auctions
[Music]